[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash remember last
time a member member last time when one
fire [__] it up and told me to start
talking about nine seconds into the
theme song well that didn't happen this
time and it's all gravy it's all good
now cuz we [__] you know we made it
and it's been smooth sailing so far it's
only been 20 seconds but it's been
smooth sailing let's let you know that
right now I'm live on my app and you
guys can get it at Crystal iya da or no
I'm sorry I had a [__] Winnie where
they do apps just type in Chris D'Elia
we're coming to Memphis Tennessee
Chattanooga Tennessee and Knoxville
Tennessee
that's the follow-the-leader tour so
that's where we're going and get your
tickets now Chris D'Elia calm and that's
that's it you know look at what kind of
shirt we got on
we should probably even just not even
say anything about it but somebody sent
me this I can't remember who I get sent
a lot of [__] okay you blow gets sent a
lot of [__] and I forget always the
caffeine and kilos guys that's who it
was but it's the Albuquerque news 13
local local news okay what is it KR q ue
q e k Kirk K Kirk Kirk's Kirk's
Wow okay Kirk why is there everything is
K on a radio which is just like the way
they did it in [__] when they first
started doing radio in 1710 and then
they put that a decay on it hi welcome
to KK kill Kara q kk r KR k qk k welcome
welcome to the KKK we're all we do all
whites all the time
KKK we play Hank Williams all day long
KKK welcome take eight
wkw do when when when when radio
announcers they really do we just was aw
you know but they really [__] go hit
home the doubled you wedge
www.unityhouston.org it's a shadow so
here we go
www CARICOM if you want to hear Justin
Bieber if you want to hear some the guy
with the Edie what is his [__] name
Edie what's his name
ed Sheeran or if you want to hear if you
want to hear Chris Bradley piece of [__]
other woman here we go alive well having
a concert crystal Brown is backstage
boots [__] under women we got a good
route log log flyball deep to Center you
know about when they go that when they
do that I love how I used to try to do
this bit on stage about how bad this is
here's an example of a comedian that
trying to do a bit on stage never
[__] worked and maybe one day I'll do
it but I don't think so because I don't
like to do impressions but I always
thought it was funny how how how what do
you call it the announcers would
announce everything that was going on in
either the baseball players life or
anything else in the world more
important than the actual baseball game
like to be like they'd be like todd
zeile steps up to bat todd zeile hails
originally from Fort Lauderdale Florida
he made his move over to the Cardinals
later on in life when he moved to st.
Louis with his family
that's his kids not his mom and dad as
mom and dad stayed in the southern tip
of Florida for most of his child
life and even well into the adult I
believe they're still there swinging a
Miss strike one
like that's how they would do it and I
would never be able to get it to work
onstage cuz it's just like a
conversational joke but that's how they
[__] do it
I would always [__] I would always I
try to do that bit maybe my maybe six
seven eight nine ten times they'd be
like hands leme Yulin steps up to bat
hailing from wherever the [__] he hails
from who knows his name is Hensley
nobody's name has ever been Hensley in
the world
his parents apparently had him come out
and when he came out of his mom's [__]
his dad said well that looks like it
Hensley might as well be from Mars
because we've never heard that name
before in our lives and it also doesn't
pair well with mule ins so that's very
odd that his name would be Hensley mule
ins keeps his eye on the ball ball one
John all Roode steps up to the plate is
batting averages 400 which is
unbelievable for some reason he was an
amazing hitter later on in the in his
career wasn't that good in the beginning
of his career and the only guy who wears
a helmet while playing first base
apparently is that much of a [__] that
he gets so scared to get hit in the head
by a baseball even though he's ready for
it because he's playing first base and
should always know when the ball is
coming to him fly ball deep to center
and he's out
anyway kay www calm
we're here at baseball the ball baseball
fights bla bla bla bla bla bla doesn't
matter uh does it ever level of metal
Lululemon pants blahblahblah George
Brett up to bat digs into the place digs
into the plate sorry said place because
George Brett [__] all over the place
last time I George Brett last night had
doubled a bird [__] and long fly ball
deep to right field eddies out and he
should have passed oh good oh good he's
take a shower go to the bishop look it's
Karen
anyway dude that's it
oh yeah there's a funny guy on Instagram
that does the really good voice
announcing the Bob memory or whatever
the [__] you guys should follow him I
forgot about him someone on my app is
letting me know that he you should
collab with him now he's got it he's way
better than I am at it he actually
sounds like the guy for real
I sound like silly [__] he sounds like
the guy for real and it makes it that
much funnier anyway anyway you know my
manager keeps hitting me up about how
[__] everyone in the business keeps
talking to him about how I'd bring him
up in the podcast which is hilarious I
never thought I never actually thought
about that but he's like people are
comes in saying and I'm kind of saying
so now I'm like okay well sorry cool
well this [__] sound plant device is
not dragging which is really pissing me
off everybody's fired everybody's fired
so yeah what did I do this week dude I'm
in town for a [__] month so what's
the deal dude what's the deal what do I
do
I chill dude I'm used to being on the
road I'm used to being on the road and I
don't know what to do and now I want to
be [__] chilling but I don't know
what to do
I've just been like sitting around
watching documentaries and [__]
watching documentaries and watching
things on Vice you know people who watch
Vice think they're better than everyone
a hundred percent people who watch Vice
laughs like this a lot when you say
something not like that they think it's
not true they go like this they left I
guess okay and then they [__]
underhandedly slam this [__] out of you
and nobody even gets that they're
slamming except for other people watch
Vice
okay yeah if that's how you think sure
but what about feelings that's what they
do people watch vice I always go like
this sure okay yeah I understand but
what about feelings
what about girls with short hair in
their feelings so yeah
vice is you know always trying to expose
[__] sometimes they expose [__] that
doesn't even need to be exposed
they're like lemons what the [__] on
Vice lemons and the guy's a girl we talk
to a lemon um and I sat down with a
lemon the lemon just on a [__] in
front of a computer on a keyboard just
to see what the daily life a level of a
lemon actually is lemon just sitting
there for [__] 12 seconds and then a
girl with [__] oversized glasses and
a ponytail is like so and she's wearing
a flannel to make her or makes a rope
order so lemon so how do you feel being
just in a society cut to the lemon just
sitting there
do you just ever feel pressure to be
juice yeah you know I feel like I don't
know sometimes in my relationships go
sour sebat joke but that's what it is
dude that's vice bro i sat down [__]
i sat down there was sitting down dude i
sat down with somebody who loves
painting just to see what their effects
are on society
so painter yeah do you ever feel like
you're in a society that's what they're
always asking how do you feel like being
in a society well you know in society I
just feel like you know painting has to
be you know more accepted because if
it's not then we're in a society that's
not accepting things and then it's like
what kind of society are we in i sat
down to fart with a chef so your advice
we sat down with the chef that's riddled
with tattoos all over their arms because
we've decided what
chef's to do in a society so chef
society
so basically society here's what it is
so girls with short hair society and we
wanted to just basically see what it was
like society and if we didn't then
there's no way I could cook crab cake
society he farted then I farted my
glasses got bigger and I threw up
everywhere and it was normal anyway dude
[__] Vice is always exposing [__]
doesn't need to be exposed you know but
it's cool I guess you know
they the one time they did were like
there's a stand-up culture in a garage
and they interviewed these guys doing
stand-up in a [__] garage hey it's
nothing
hey get out cars they're the underground
culture of stand-ups not being accepted
got in the club they don't feel accepted
so they started stand-up in a garage
good and everyone that were like chairs
set up in the garage where the car
should be and everyone laughs everyone
[__] everyone outside of comedy clubs
that do stand-up the outside of comedy
clubs everyone laughs like this ha ha ha
like they're [__] Vince Vaughn on
ritalin dude get out I know so many
people are gonna be upset but like
whatever dude lets it is hilarious
that [__] is [__] hilarious dude we
caught up with this underground stand-up
comedy brigade they just stand up in a
forest
they have pointy ears cuz they're [__]
gnomes but they're accepted and everyone
laughs like I did I did
what happened I did stand-up in one of
those [__] things once and everyone
was laughing like that and I was like
dude you're not even really [__]
laughing and whatever you know hey do
you honestly do it wherever the [__]
look here's the other thing to do it
wherever the [__] you want I don't give
a [__] I'm just making fun of it you
know there's stand-up comedy shows in a
[__] laundromat you know do it if you
get a people there and they want to pay
and if they feel good paying and they
feel like they're supporting then who
gives a [__] dude I don't want you to
come to my show
to support I want you to come to my show
cuz you want to laugh that's what I want
people are like yeah you got a support
live comedy dude come to laugh support
somebody with cancer come to my show to
laugh but whatever whatever makes you
feel good at the end of the day whatever
makes you feel good do it if you want to
do a show for a bunch of [__] guys
that sound like Vince Vaughn on [__]
paid killers then do it anyway your
advice we caught up with a [__]
turkey with glasses on it shit's so
Turkey do you ever feel like [__] in
a society very cool guy with tattoos on
his arms so we caught up with a bunch of
turkeys in Iraq and they made actually a
great point that I I don't know man dude
you know what I've been getting a bunch
of [__] texts and [__] and people
telling me how khuda this is a lot of
times people don't understand what real
qu - it is they just call people khuda
because they don't know what the term is
we coined the term khuda here it's from
barracuda and you're a khuda if you do
something just because you see it and
someone else maybe says it's a good idea
you're like what's that oh cool I'll do
it like a barracuda sees a [__]
diamond bracelet and then looks at it
and says what's that
Coachella number one Kota thing here is
a super CUDA [__] okay by the way
where's the timer here I don't even see
how long one right there okay these
people there's like a climbing Mount
Everest is I get an alt
hi and it's because of [__] Instagram
because they want to get this picture at
the summit at the top of the [__]
mountain and people are dying didn't 11
people died this year 11 people died
this year too many and it looks like a
goddamn traffic jam it looks like it
would be in a [__] like fish market
in China like how long the line is for
people trying to get up to this summit
dude it was like a zoo this person says
death on an unruly overcrowded Everest
look at this picture a long line of
climbers waiting to summit Mount Everest
on May 22nd
dude this is a nightmare
I don't want to be in [__] Hawaii in
a line like this and they're on a
mountain on a high one they can't
breathe their lips are chapped they're
in [__] North Face gear at least
they're keeping warm in their North Face
gear but dude
they've got packs on their backs they've
got parents on the banks and then
they're like getting their cameras these
[__] asses with their cameras ready
just on almost dying look at this hi mom
love you and that was the last note her
ma his mom her mom ever seen you can't
tell if it's a man a woman because he's
covered up so much because it's way too
cold and if he takes anything off or she
takes anything off surely she or he will
immediately get frostbite and I look at
this go up a little bit there was just a
quote a little bit more there I was not
prepared to see sick climbers being
dragged down the mountain by Sherpas or
surreal or the surreal experience of
finding dead bodies he said well really
hey I've got it I've got it hey dude
that's crazy man well you know what
you're a bonafide [__] idiot you
didn't expect to see sick people or dead
bodies at the top of Mount Everest well
dude this just in doot-doot-doot dude
you're a [__] bonehead [__] do this
just in you're a bonehead ah you didn't
expect to see dead bodies
where there are dead bodies hat well I
can't do a [__] drive-by hat because
you're on the top of Mount Everest so
how about this I'll climb by hat people
with photos are I mean no [__]
whatever it is people always want the
picture people sometimes want pictures
of meat they don't even know who I am
they just saw somebody take a picture
with me they're like can I get a picture
I go like this Who am I and they go like
this
we on Entourage and I go I go really
slowly no picture for you - that's not
theme of gangsta's Paradise hahahaha
what if I was that much of a lunatic I
gotta get there dude I swear to God I
gotta get there that's my dream to be
like a [__] guy that just I wish I
didn't like part of me wishes I didn't
have a conscious conscious conscious
conscious I always [__] that up like I'm
my opener conscience somebody goes like
this can I have a picture Who am I
oh I don't know your name but I think I
saw you on Netflix and I just go No
Oh picture olena picture rain then then
then then then then then and I just keep
doing that until they get so [__]
weird and awkward and walk away and the
dude I was getting out to get coffee and
there was a note ozone this was today
there was no tow there's like a towaway
zone it was like a towaway zone was like
you can't park here so I parked there
because if there's a parking space I'm
gonna [__] sit do it dude it's so
annoying one thing places are like don't
park and you're like why I get it if
there's like a whole [__] thing and
it's like all because any people can't
get out the thing I don't to block
anybody dude there's no [__] reason
for the tow a [__] so I parked there cuz
I'm a person and I'm in a car and I need
to [__] get out so I parked there and
then I got into the I got out of my car
and by the way four cars could could fit
and this guy parks in front of me and he
says moment is elem or whatever the [__]
I don't listen to people when they say
something for the first time because who
are you and why you know just a random
person also I'm not ready get out the
car with the with the girl and this guy
goes oh moments uploading some dumb and
I say oh yeah and I look at her and I
don't know what the [__] he says and he
says and he and then he says or not and
I was like oh this [__] getting
passive-aggressive on me dude how do you
know what the [__] he said and he's
getting some or not or not dude you know
what or not is for texting only only and
even still you should just write lol hey
want to go to the baseball game no text
back next day lol or K you don't write
or not like you're a [__] you know
what I mean
that's so [__] but I'm would maybe do
or not on text but in person dude
look at somebody and be like this or not
what are you doing chew down so he
[__] goes or not and I look over and
of course he's shorter than me nobody
who is taller than somebody ever says or
not to the person that's just not how it
goes you are saying or not to somebody
congratulations you're shorter than them
there's no [__] way if I'm six to the
guy who is saying or not to me is six
three there's no [__] way so I look
over he's five five nine obviously okay
and I say oh man sorry I didn't hear you
and he says okay and I realized he was
saying I rewound it you know how you can
do that sometimes you could do the what
sometimes you're like what and you
didn't hear it but sometimes you're like
what and you were like wait a minute
don't repeat yourself
I can rewind time in my head and hear
the [__] so I rewound it you can go back
like [__] nine seconds maybe at the
most maybe I'm a [__] mutant maybe
that's my power I don't know but I
rewound it and I realized I went I went
over the [__] sound scan that he did
and I'm a little bit and I rewound it
and I don't know and I turned it into
what he said which was oh you should
have something you should have
he said Reza oh you should have you you
could have moved back and or you could
have moved up and we both could have
parked there and I was like this guy and
I'm in the coffee place and I'm looking
at him and he's just in the coffee place
like this with his phone cuz he's
picking up for uber eats
he's just literally in the coffee place
like this holding his [__] phone out
like this like he's like he's looking
like it like it's that [__] new thing
uber or lyft does where they make your
phone screen pink so you could tell when
[__] Oh George is trying to pick you
up
by the way in LA if you [__] get an
uber guy his name's Oh George I don't
give a [__] what you who you think is
there I've never gotten an uber where
guy's name is an old York so like hey
how can I get a Pete can I get a hey
Chris hey it's Chris you you Chris yeah
you Oh George of course we all all joke
so it's over isn't it yeah get in okay
cool
get abducted by some other old York so
now I was the wrong old George I'm going
to take you in a hut and rape you so
then so anyway so I get to the what the
[__] was I talk about yeah so then I get
out to look at this Park job I did right
cuz of course I get out after he leaves
cuz he's in a [__] hurry you know so
I get out after and I look and by the
way dude
[__] no [__] where I parked not
even if I had parked the way he said for
other cars could have fit no [__]
not an exaggeration for other cars could
have picked and I said what the [__] is
the deal what this guy just wants a
complain bro you know it's like this
guy's gonna make me do some [__] ads
right now that's the thing
this guy's gonna make me do some [__]
you know what this guy's gonna make me
do without a care in the world that's
what I'm gonna do dude oh you're gonna
[__] okay well guess what dude oh you
know what oh you could have moved
forward
you could have moved forward and and we
both could have parked there oh really
well how about instead of moving forward
I backup the [__] Brinks truck
blue apron look now I've been saying
this for years but nothing says summers
finally here like a classic juicy burger
or whipping up a fresh tomato salsa or
sharing a delicious meal alfresco this
season experienced the joy of cooking
something new trying new to you textin
techniques and make make cooking fun
again with blue apron it's really fun I
do it and with an ever-changing mix of
meat fish and vegetarian recipes to
choose from it'll be your tastiest
summer yet blue apron helps me discover
my inner chef and learn new recipes and
techniques and now guess what daddy
loves cooking blue apron has exposed me
to delicious recipes I wouldn't even
have thought to try I have yet to have a
bad meal from blue apron it's amazing it
really is helps me make cooking a
sustainable part of my weekly routine
because of my hectic schedule I felt
like I know their choice than to go out
to eat more than I should I save money
and I also eat healthier upcoming meals
include prosciutto pizza prosciutto
pizza spiced fish and avocado tacos
seared chicken and creamy lime sauce to
start making delicious brag worthy meals
Instagram post worthy meals at home
without the hassle try blue apron check
out this week's menu and get $60 off
when you visit blue apron commish
Congrats that's blue apron dot-com /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
post mates when you need red wine at 4
p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. a breakfast burrito
at 8 a.m. and ibuprofen at 10 a.m.
post made it they got you covered post
mates is your personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery service all year round
whatever you're craving postmates scan
deliver I do it all the time almost
every other day maybe every three days
but I love it they're the largest
on-demand network in the US and offer
delivery from all the restaurants and
grocery places and all the convenience
stores you need 24 hours a day doesn't
stop if the stores open they post mates
it and it's awesome you don't even have
to know where the store is the post
mates does all that
dirty work so download the app for iOS
or Android for free browse local
restaurants and businesses they also
have suggestions it's just really great
for a limited time post makes postmates
says giving our listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
post made it
download post mates and save with code
Congrats goat you know I'm a shoe guy
you know I like easiest Jordans off
whites and you know what app has all of
them goat if you're going to buy
sneakers for a few hundred dollars how
can you be sure that they're the real
thing
goat comm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online the
biggest Mart largest market place in the
world for authentic Easy's Jordans and
over 600,000 sneaker listings they've
made the whole process very easy and
trustworthy most importantly because if
you get it on another website there's a
stone store it could be fake so don't do
that that's not the right saying but you
know what I'm talking about there's a
chance it might be fake every detail is
inspected from the stitching to the
colors to the size and weight it
certifies every pair and sneakers every
pair of sneakers is the exact factory
specifications look 10 million users
they can't be wrong you won't find
better prices or verified 100 authentic
sneakers anywhere else find the perfect
100% authentic sneaker at Goat Comstock
Congrats that's goat comm / Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
but you've got to go right now before
the sneakers you want are gone when you
go to goat comm / congrats spelled Geo
80 comm / congrats congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app the most
popular app named cash app so that's how
it's gonna be through a right one
firefighers face didn't mean to that
that's the way the cookie crumbles and
i'm very sorry but you know i through I
meant to throw it at the [__] camera
went right in one fires goddamn face and
now let me tell you something also
what's super annoying you know when
people go have a deal when you were like
in high school or some [__] or not even
high school but you throw a trash away
and you try to [__] make it in the
bin and then they go like this Wow and
you play basket Wow and you play
basketball and you miss wow you put
basketball
it's [__] nothing like it okay case
closed that's it and I'm not talking
about that anymore and we're not doing
that anymore nobody does it
you're a [__] straight-up [__] if
you do that if somebody tries to throw
some way and they go this isn't like wow
you'll be able terrible basketball
player or oh wow you go oh you play
basketball that's weird you can't even
make that yo case closed we're not
talking about anymore we're not doing
that and I'm not and I'm done talking
about it that's it case closed there's
the rules of my babies and if you don't
think there's rules you're part of the
problem I just need to get this [__]
cult going I need to get this cult going
and I need to get this [__] log-cabin
going I need [__] builders I need
carpenters and I need weed whackers
that's two for starters I need people to
go down and whack the weeds find the
[__] place where we're gonna put it
builders to do it and carpenters to lay
the [__] down and then after that I'm
gonna need some [__] food people and
you know some [__] and suckers dude
because we got a bus nuts when we're at
the log cabin don't you understand don't
you understand one fire wrote ads to
remind me to do ads I did the ads ads is
still on the [__] TV it's fine
it's just a little bit step towards one
fighter and it's fine but that's how it
is I was talking to my friend and she
was saying that remember I was talking
about house people that live in other
people's houses and otherwise I talk
about the five top 5 scariest stop top 5
scariest scariest things caught in a
GoPro camera and I was talking to my
friend and she was saying that she had a
friend in Chicago that was on that was
that was there in in the in
she moved in I guess in the summer and
she kept hearing like rats in the Attic
and then when it was cold out there was
still shuffling around she's like damn
I gotta call somebody she's called the
called the police or somebody or like
the fireman or something like
something's up there you know some
animals up there they're like animal
control or something like well why don't
you try and go up there and look around
she was like fine so she put a selfie
stick on put a phone on the selfie stick
to go take the picture took a few shots
just up in the attic and [__] brought
the phone down and looked and there was
a guy in the attic dude there was a guy
a man in the Attic yeah we sure will
show the picture on the [__] video
podcast we maybe blow out the guy's face
apparently was just some homeless guy
that was like doing his I get the cops
game was like ya know he does this oh
well how about keep him yeah I know he
does this every time we let him out oh
really
keep him hold that guy do you have cells
put him in there put him in the Attic of
the [__] cop place of the prison I
mean so insane just know what I would do
squirt [__] everywhere if that happened
to me I go like this first of all I go
like this to the [__] people you want
me to what go up there and snoop around
hmm you must have me confused with Jason
Statham what's your second option is
what I do
thinking like this well maybe you want
to go up there and I say huh
what's your second option and
say selfie stick with a cellphone and I
go like this
convince me and then they after they
convinced me for a while ago okay
and I do it and I take a few pictures I
bring the phone down and if I see the
picture that the person [__] showed
me the other night of the guy in the
Attic that's when I release my bowels
that's when I [__] all over my Easy's I
go like this I go like this and then I
bring the foam down look at it and I say
I got to get new Yeezys that's what I
say immediately ah [__] I gotta get new
Yeezys and then I go and run out I don't
get scared first
oh my Jordans are Brown and run away I
go hey when you get hey when you get out
of this attic you're gonna have to
[__] watch er watch out are you gonna
slip and then I run and I [__] all the
way down my stairs down my stairs to the
first level and then down to my driveway
oh I got [__] all in my Aston Martin
that's what I got my babies and I drove
all the way to the police station I said
all over there
vice did a thing about in today we sit
down with an in cell have you ever heard
about these in cells have you heard
about in cells have you heard about in
cells dude these guys are like guys that
like don't they think that I don't even
like they don't have they don't get
chicks number one involuntary celibacy
it stands for and in cells by just
there's this article here that came up
so in cells are involuntary celibate so
they don't have sex and they want to and
let me just tell you something because I
was reading this article on the cut how
many bones would you break to get laid
in cells are going under the knife too
shaped their faces and they're dating
prospects so butters shut the [__] up
butters you're an in cell so they
basically are like oh they think they're
not like good-looking or something or
they're like you know depressed and in
their 20s or not and they could be old
older but they just can't get laid and
there's a community online for them and
they all like they bash women a lot
right and they talk [__] about how women
don't women you know a lot of a lot of
them I don't know if some of them do but
a lot of the stuff I read has been like
oh yeah because women are [__] and
they take selfies because they won they
take selfies because they say [__] like
they they take selfies because they have
a [__] and they don't and it's not big
enough to penetrate someone so they
can't feel confident because they don't
penetrate someone else so they result in
getting attention by taking [__]
horror pics on on Instagram and posting
them now what I have to say is that is a
backwards and your dad died early okay
and Sal guy it's all good your your mom
died early so so what they're saying is
there are these guys called they call
them Chad's which is [__] hilarious
and sells good job on calling them
Chad's that they like these guys like
the girls like these chats because they
have like square jaws and they're just
cool looking and they have confidence
and we don't have confidence they're
saying part of its kind of sad also just
a lot of these guys you could just be
like yo go outside though you know these
guys are just behind the computer not
getting laid I can get laid behind the
computer bro so some of these guys I
guess look in the quote here in cells
have this idea of an ideal Superman and
this guy is one who does that crazy
stuff I guess I don't know
oh they the doctor I guess that they're
trying to make him look here oh this is
the oh the elliot rodger guy was an
insult the the guy who killed all the I
think who he says here in cell named
Elliot Roger who called himself a
supreme gentleman I mean I mean anyone
who calls himself a supreme gentleman
you gotta watch out for I'll say that
much wrote in a manifesto that the world
had failed to provide the beautiful
girlfriend I know and deserve at some
any problems before he killed six people
in injured 14 in a shooting spree in
Isla Vista California sorority house
yeah in the past decades seven mass
killings have been attributed to in
cells or adjacent online misogynists
yeah yeah anyway it's [__] up
obviously but cuz changing your jaw size
isn't gonna get you laid go outside and
I know it's something people have like
no confidence but you gotta just have
you've got to just try if you don't try
I mean what the [__] do I know I'm
probably had Chad according to these
guys but you've got to just put you
literally I remember the first time I
was gonna do stand-up I was like there's
no way I'm gonna be able to get on stage
and I just thought okay let's break it
down to my physical body if I just take
if I just move one foot in front of my
body and then keep moving the opposite
foot in front of the opposite foot in
front of the opposite foot over into the
direction of this stage then I'll be on
stage and then I will have been on stage
and I have done the first step and then
I will have to start talking and if I
don't then oh well I [__] I tried at
least you try break it down to your
physical body dude these guys you might
be a
Chadd deep down you don't know I was
looking at this one for him and this one
guy was like yeah what is it with a lot
of these girls they like guys who I
always like I I have to start listening
to rap music because a lot of Chad's
listen to rap music and I just don't
like it it's monotonous to me and I know
that a lot of these these girls like
guys who like rap music cuz these guys
will post inane rap lyrics on Facebook
and these girls will fall all over them
and and he's like is there any way I
could start listening to rap do you guys
under do you guys can you let guide me
into like beginner rap listening like
and I was just like what the [__] dude
what
there's listing the music doesn't
require steps first of all second of all
just cuz you listen to lil yachty
doesn't mean your dicks gonna get wet
imagine if it was that easy
they'd it's these in cells make it seem
so hard and so easy to get laid at the
same time it's neither it's just [__]
case-by-case dude some of these guys are
not even bad-looking they're really not
some of them are like [__]
heroin-chic [__] that could
probably be a like a Gucci model I mean
it's not it's like this [__]
they think it's gonna be like this damn
lil yachty huh
damn Louie Gotti looks like is a red
tarantula and his head doesn't he what's
he doing dude when I look at little
yachties head I think man I want candy
um anyway uh yeah so watch out for them
in sales man the internet's such a weird
[__] thing there's I [__] online
there's a [__] girl on Instagram I'm
stretching dude I don't give a [__] you
got a stretch sometimes there's a girl
on Instagram that's got 1.6 million
followers and just talks about her day
and she's did [__] oh she dreams and it
oh what's that song dude what's that
song dude one time I was I was in my 20s
and I was I was a roommate with these
other with this guy and his sister and I
was room I was roommates with them and I
and I heard that song and all day I was
young she dreams and dead uh and they
were like shut the [__] up dude I was
almost been annoying that was before I
did standup
oh yeah the band's name is orgy wow dude
band's name is orgy they really went
with it ah let's play a little bit of
that song this is what we do baby is
that even how it goes is probably so
different I thought I remembered it it's
probably so different
[Music]
Wow so a 90s
yeah sir 9 DS
[Music]
yep there it is
Wow she dreams in digital anyway thanks
for G for that song and a lot in the
world and so this girl is digital she's
a fake chick that somebody just creates
and she's called lo Michaela
sounds like could be a [__]
soundcloud rapper um anyway this [__]
chick is a fake girl that somebody
created and it has the same amount of
followers as I have the [__] dude I work
hard I tour the country I come out with
content and this [__] chick is just
fake with a fake hat and people follow
her look at this [__] she's by a pool in
a bathing suit with a hat holding the
Hat and she says I have so many things
I'm supposed to be doing right now but
I'm not doing any of it and wishing I
was sitting at this pool instead no hey
you don't have anything you're supposed
to be doing you're not real and somebody
wrote rule breaker she's not a [__]
rule breaker dude she doesn't she
doesn't [__] break or follow rules
you know why she dreams in digital
[Music]
that's why dude that's [__] why
that's why she's not breaking rules I
mean dude here's a let me look at some
of our other posts by the way can't find
it can't find it pissed pissed pissed
beyond all belief can't find it can't
find it
oh dude where is it what is it Ernie oh
I went to that's because I went out of
it
little Makayla uh there we go little me
Kayla Instagram clicking on it here's
the [__] things here let's just go to
the last one for my cover shoot with
that yeah you know nobody's shot [__]
here's another one yeah I think I'm
ready to let my hair down again maybe
you know what what dude
no I don't know what to say to this [__]
honestly leave this one here things to
celebrate the house passing Equality Act
okay well that's fine but you're still
fake so uh huh
here's one where she there's another
digital thing of what's that happy Adi
did Bella Hadid or ha beep what the [__]
is her name whatever I am here this is
my truth she writes and she's with Bella
Hadid or whatever [__] name is and
somebody writes you're a lesbian I'm
shook what no let me just look at this
person's profile who says you're a
lesbian I'm shook she's not a lesbian
no I not purse
she's digital dude how she a lesbian
when she dreams in digital so annoying
was a lesbian her so many things if
you'd let their hand would it dreams and
you want to go let's do [__] uh uh
[__] craigslist ads craigslist
misconnections here we go were we doing
it Carlsbad San Diego you didn't mean to
send it to me well he did and I'm pissed
here we go car this you were picking up
Rubio's to go in Carlsbad Oh Rubio's to
go in Carlsbad you were an attractive
black guy with athletic clothes on
grabbing food to go that Rubio's on El
Camino Real
I was the tall blonde getting salsa
that's how somehow the grossest one I've
ever read just some [__] tall chick
scooping up salsa looking at some
[__] athletic some some black eye in
like adidas do not contact me
unsolicited service robbers yes pretty
specific dude that's so funny cause like
she thinks that maybe he would have been
like oh yeah saw this girl getting salsa
like just guys don't notice that the
girls getting salsa if he's attracted to
her you know just say saw yet Rubio's
the any guy at Rubio's would be like oh
it's probably me oh it's probably me
yeah I was getting salsa
oh I don't give a [__] you have a [__]
I was getting salsa though oh the one
with the tits yeah no I was near the
guacamole oh you got mouth and stuff
let's do another one
ah this is the most confusing whenever
it's for words long the title is two
words lasting batteries okay the body is
very bored
okay did not contact me unsolicited well
what's the [__] solicited offer
what's the [__] what do you mean do
not contact notice unsolicited offers
you're bored well what's the [__]
thing you're supposed to get solicited
with think before you get on Craigslist
list in San Diego aka the worst [__]
place of all time I'd rather get run
over by a [__] Zamboni than be in San
Diego here's another one Asian woman not
sure ah sir racist you were dancing with
your kids son and daughter in the garage
creep you seem like someone fun to hang
out with I left early but hope you see
this and say what I mean left early you
shouldn't have been there period hey I
meant to creep on you for longer but I
had to go I was scheduled to [__]
look at someone else in the garage
I was I was scheduled to wash I was
scheduled to watch I think some [__]
middle-eastern lady maybe will shower
through a curtain I was I was booked I
was busy I left early I could sorry I
can only stay 45 minutes watch you
dancing with your sons in the garage wow
this guy [__] dreams with booze ooh
man all these [__] ones take place at
the worst [__] establishments dude
this one saw at Del Taco
dude Del Taco [__] sucks have you
ever been to Del Taco holy [__] it's
like eating a wall do del Taco del tacos
tacos they taste like a prolapsed anus
dude if you if you eat by the way
burgers it burgers at Del Taco for let
me tell you something right now
burgers at Del Taco oh no [__]
burgers at Del Taco no [__]
burgers at the if you put a burger in
your mouth at burgers in your in your
mouth in Del Taco
DJ kevy
and you just start stomping you go like
this you eat one you like this talk and
you just get better Loretta in this
rhythm and then if you eat a [__]
taco from Del Taco I'll tell you right
now it tastes like [__] [__] the
tacos in del tacos hey dude [__] your
your Del Taco it says taco have the
tacos be good but they're not dude and I
used to go at least once a week in the
valley to get the [__] burgers when I
was a kid and I would eat that trash has
fast food and it was my idea one fire is
reminding me that we used to go and yes
I used to go get it and I used to eat it
but only the [__] burgers
del Taco but not the tacos only burgers
[Music]
del Taco only burgers dude have you ever
been with a [__] person who doesn't
get a cheeseburger and gets a hamburger
get out of here I swear to God
are you [__] are you a communist are
you a lunatic if somebody doesn't get
cheese on their cheat on their burger by
the way it's a cheese but even call a
cheeseburger if you get a burger the
cheese is coming baby you got to not
order the cheese if I say yeah like a
hamburger you don't bring cheese I'm out
this [__] dude and I'm going to [__]
Ralph's
or for shop right and getting cheese and
[__] eating it all day long just as a
[__] diss we eat jeez Wow
this is the worst podcast I've ever done
in my life but it's all good dude so
crass so crass so unsecured how he says
yeah yeah is there any more morons
instigated our roll for real he's 42 he
sits on a Conn shoulders and they're
[__] awful person
so many people in the house so many
people shouting out it's already been a
minute
so many places places yeah I'll say
they call me as my favorite when rappers
do that you made the name okay it's been
over a minute that's the question I
didn't know he said the n-word because I
would just hear that I would just hear
the the radio edit when the and I would
we goes let's take and I was like yeah
that's cool and then when I heard him
say the n-word and the real version I
was like oh I was like the [__] the
wee-bey meme oh you see that mean anyway
is that it or what dude [__] dork
okay dude what if I [__] got in a
fight with ja rule for real I'd have to
[__] he'd beat the [__] out of me I
hope all right I'm done dude this is it
man we did it
thank you that was a good that was a fun
one man download the cash up for free on
the App Store or Google Play market and
download the crystal Lea app you can
listen to the app I get it you can [__]
it and you know hear the story you can
[__] download the app and you can
hear hear the podcast and watch the
pockets before anybody else sees it or
hears it live and there's merch at Chris
D'Elia store Chris Lea calm the restock
is continuous keep a look at keep a look
out and subscribe to the YouTube channel
the podcast was a little late this week
and thank you I won't miss a week but it
was a little weak a little late and I
wanted you guys to understand that I was
I was
okay cuz I got a special thing coming
for you guys anyway thanks for listening
please comment and subscribe and share
this do it we got to get the log cabin
go on we need more builders so everybody
who listen to this podcast go tell one
of your friends or a stranger to listen
to the podcast thank you and I'll see
you soon Tennessee
[Music]